This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一个I-Heart播客。保证真人。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收看《以艰难的方式学习》（Learn the Hardway），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）。这个节目聚焦黑人男性的经历，进行在其他地方绝对不安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个懂行的执照专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着一套坚甲利兵。这向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。但这并不意味着你必须这么做，点击收听。
the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier,
在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《以艰难的方式学习》。2%。这是当电梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端变成一个更快乐、
more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方搜索TWO%。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 is big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方，收听《相信闺蜜，相信我，宝贝》。在《回顾过去》（Look Back at It）播客中。从1979年开始，这对我和我来说都是一个重要时刻。84年对我很重要。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。
With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you want.
和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）聊80年代。84年是个疯狂的年份。那真是个疯狂的年份。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾过去》。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》（The Psychology of Your 20s），这是一个探讨我们在二十岁时经历的一些重大生活变化和转变，以及它们对我们的心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。新听众、老听众，无论你在哪里。
are in the world, you know the deal. Welcome back for another episode. Today, we are going to take a deep look into what psychology has to say about the healing power of nature. Nature, the outdoors, time spent by the beach, in greenery, the forest. They are such an incredibly profound sense of joy and peace for so many good reasons. It relieves stress. It allows us to step away from our monotonous routines, it actively rewires our brain in such a positive way. And the research and benefits are honestly endless. And we're going to talk about all of them because I think it is so profound and the impact that nature can have on our psychological well-being does not get the recognition it deserves. However, as a generation, I think we have become more and more detached from this
在世界各地，你知道的规矩。欢迎收看新的一期节目。今天，我们将深入探讨心理学对大自然的治愈力量的看法。大自然、户外、在海滩上、在绿地中、在森林里度过的时光。由于许多充分的理由，它们带来了极其深远的快乐和平静感。它能缓解压力。它让我们得以从单调的日常中抽身出来，它以一种非常积极的方式积极地重塑我们的大脑。而且研究和益处老实说永无止境。我们将探讨所有这些，因为我认为这意义重大，大自然对我们心理健康的深远影响并没有得到它应有的认可。然而，作为一个世代，我认为我们已经变得越来越脱离这种
natural urge and instinct from our drive towards kind of the wilderness. Technology and social media in particular consume so much of our time. We are spending more time indoors than any other generation. Most of us living in huge cities. And we've become very severed from this innate need. I've even noticed that in my own life. You know, there are so many days that I just don't go outdoors. And that makes me feel so stagnant and unhealthy.
自然的冲动和本能，脱离了我们对荒野的那种渴望。科技，尤其是社交媒体，占去了我们大量的时间。我们呆在室内的时间比以往任何一代人都要多。我们大多数人都住在巨大的城市里。我们与这种与生俱来的需求已经严重割裂。我甚至在自己的生活中也注意到了这一点。你知道，有很多天我根本不出门。这让我感到非常停滞不前和不健康。
And just really detached from what I know my brain needs, this like very deep need. And the consequences of that are becoming so apparent, not just personally and anecdotally, but we're seeing increasing problems with attention, overall life satisfaction, social skills, connection. It's even created these new terms like nature deficit disorder, showing us that this alienation from our natural environment is really creating a lot of problems. So today I want to discuss the studies and the science behind the healing power of nature and how to implement that in our lives. We're going to look at all the evidence, especially from this new
并且真的与我知道我大脑需要的东西脱节了，这是一种非常深的需求。其后果正变得越来越明显，不仅在个人和轶事层面上，而且我们看到注意力、整体生活满意度、社交技能、连接方面的问题越来越多。它甚至创造了诸如“大自然赤字障碍”（nature deficit disorder）之类的新词，向我们表明这种与自然环境的疏离确实造成了很多问题。所以今天我想讨论自然治愈力量背后的研究和科学，以及如何在我们的生活中落实这一点。我们将审视所有的证据，尤其是来自这个新
discipline of ecoc psychology, but also some of the origins of this understanding from the idea of forest bathing in Japan, forest schools in Scandinavia, and some really amazing techniques and just general philosophies and understanding from some indigenous cultures in Australia and New Zealand. What I find particularly fascinating is probably not the word, maybe a little bit disturbing, is that Western psychology in particular is often really dismissive of how nature can be integrated into our treatment for mental health symptoms and conditions. And it just kind of pathologizes us. We're so preoccupied with finding a label for things and with pharmaceuticals, which definitely
生态心理学（ecopsychology）学科的证据，还有这种理解的一些起源，比如日本的森林浴（forest bathing）、斯堪的纳维亚的森林学校（forest schools），以及澳大利亚和新西兰一些原住民的一些非常棒的技术以及总体哲学和理解。我发现特别着迷的可能不是这个词，也许有点令人不安的是，尤其是西方心理学通常真的很轻视自然如何能够融入我们对心理健康症状和状况的治疗中。它只是把我们病理化了。我们太专注于为事物寻找标签以及药物治疗，这当然
have their place. But I think that we've really lost touch with that holistic perspective. So I also really want to kind of explore how we can integrate exposure to nature into our daily routine from the big things to the daily rituals and the impact that we might just see on our lifestyle and our emotional and mental health and sense of fulfillment. It's a huge episode. There is so much to cover and some of my favorite psychology of the day is coming from this new discipline. So I really cannot wait to share it. Also, if you are not yet subscribed to my Patreon, please make sure to go and follow me over there. You'll get our
有它们的位置。但我认为我们确实已经失去了与那种整体视角的联系。所以我也非常想探讨我们如何将接触大自然融入我们的日常生活中，从大事到日常仪式，以及我们可能会在生活方式、情感、心理健康和成就感上看到的冲击。这是一集内容厚重的节目。有太多内容要涵盖，而我今天最喜欢的一些心理学观点正来自于这个新兴学科。所以我真的迫不及待地想分享它。另外，如果你还没有订阅我的Patreon，请务必去那里关注我。你将获得我们的
to bonus content, new episodes, episode transcripts, studies, a newsletter, so many good things. So I really appreciate the support. So many of you have already showed me. Without further ado, let's discuss the healing power of nature and all of the science and psychology supporting our need to reconnect. I'm so excited. I cannot stress this enough if you're feeling a bit lost, a bit disconnected from yourself, this is essential listening. So without further ado, let's get into it. I think every single one of us has this intuitive understanding that nature is an incredibly vital ingredient for our well-being, one that we have become very much detached from
专属福利内容、新节目、节目文字稿、研究报告、时事通讯，以及许许多多好东西。所以我非常感谢你们给予的支持。你们中的许多人已经向我表达了这一点。闲话少说，让我们来探讨自然的治愈力量，以及所有支持我们重新建立联系的需求的科学和心理学。我太激动了。我怎么强调都不为过，如果你觉得有点迷失，觉得与自己有点脱节，这是必听节目。所以废话不多说，让我们切入正题。我认为我们每个人都有这种直觉上的理解，即自然是我们福祉中极其重要的一个组成部分，而我们已经变得非常脱离它
due to this increasingly technology-based society. Just, you know, 50, even 40, 30 years ago, we lived in a completely different world in which the outdoors and nature, they were our entertainment. They were a deeply valuable part of our everyday lives when our attention was not constantly being pulled a million different directions by social media and smartwatches and office screens. There's been this massive societal and environmental pivot that our generation, those in our 20s, have experienced and are continuing to kind of witness. Someone said this to me the other day and it kind of like stopped me because I'd never thought about it, but we are perhaps the last group of people who experienced at least some of our childhood
由于这个日益以技术为基础的社会。你知道，就在50年前，甚至40年、30年前，我们生活在一个完全不同的世界里，在那里，户外和自然是我们的娱乐。它们是我们日常生活中有价值的一部分，当时我们的注意力并没有被社交媒体、智能手表和办公屏幕拉向一百万个不同的方向。我们这一代人，即那些二十多岁的人，已经经历了并将继续见证这种巨大的社会和环境转变。前几天有人对我说起这件事，它让我有些语塞，因为我从未这样想过，但我们也许是最后一群经历过至少部分童年的人。
or our lives without screens. We can still remember running down to the local park after school, riding our bikes around, climbing trees, playing in the mud. all of these really crucial elements of play that relied on nature as the stimuli, not something inorganic. And I think although we've only just started to see what this shift is doing to young kids and this new generation, innately, we know that time spent outdoors is never time wasted and that we feel better when we experience nature compared to the alternatives of spending
或没有屏幕的生活。我们依然记得放学后跑向当地的公园，骑着自行车到处转悠，爬树，在泥地里玩耍。所有这些真正关键的、依赖自然作为刺激物的玩耍元素，而不是某种非自然的东西。我认为，尽管我们才刚刚开始看到这种转变对小孩子和新一代产生的影响，但从本能上讲，我们知道花在户外的时光绝不是浪费时间，与花费大量时间相比，当我们体验大自然时，我们会感觉更好。
hours and hours scrolling on our phones. That's something that has changed. And for the first time in humanity's history, we are spending more time indoors. We have a very limited diversity of experiences. The other shift that I think is important here is that we're seeing that by 2050, maybe earlier, it's been projected by scientists, by researchers,
几个小时又几个小时地刷手机。这就是改变的地方。在人类历史的第一次，我们花在室内的时间更多了。我们的体验多样性非常有限。我认为这里重要的另一个转变是，我们看到到2050年，或者更早，科学家、研究人员预测，
that two-thirds of humanity will be living in our lives. cities or urban areas. We are becoming more and more severed from those evolutionary roots. And this has even inspired this new term that I was speaking about before, nature deficit disorder. The idea, and it was really only introduced back in 2005, so less than 20 years ago, it claims that humans were spending less time outdoors, and this is resulting in a sense of really deep alienation and a wide range of behavioral problems, especially amongst children. And I will say it's not a diagnosable medical condition as of yet,
三分之二的人类将生活在城市或城市地区。我们正变得越来越脱离那些进化之根。这甚至激发了我之前谈到的一个新词，即“大自然赤字障碍”（nature deficit disorder）。这个概念最早是在2005年被引入的，距今还不到20年，它声称人类花在户外的时日减少，这导致了一种非常深的疏离感以及广泛的行为问题，特别是在儿童当中。我要说的是，到目前为止，它还不是一种可诊断的医疗状况，
but there is this expanding body of scientific evidence that suggests that a nature deficit disorder contributes to a diminished use of our senses, attention difficulties, greater problems with emotional regulation, and also just a lack of natural curiosity. These researchers, particularly the person who created this term, what they're suggesting is that this experience, this trend is really weakening our ecological literacy and that children in this generation, we are caring less and less about the natural world, which is super problematic when we consider things like climate change where we need people to care, we need people to want to protect these spaces.
但越来越多的科学证据表明，大自然赤字障碍导致了我们感官使用的减少、注意力困难、情绪调节方面更大的问题，以及缺乏自然好奇心。这些研究人员，特别是创造这个词的人，他们所指出的是，这种经历、这种趋势确实在削弱我们的生态素养，这一代的儿童对自然世界的关心越来越少，当我们考虑到气候变化等需要人们关心、需要人们想要保护这些空间的事情时，这是非常有问题的。
But these problems are also linked more broadly to what health experts call an epidemic of inactivity. Our lives are indoors. They are contained. And we are very much missing out on how much healing nature can provide us. This understanding actually has a lot of scientific backing, so much so that researchers have created an entirely new discipline called ecopsychology to examine this very universal experience. So eco-psychology is interested in understanding how we can increase the connection between individuals and the natural environment for the purpose of treating certain mental health conditions or promoting connection, remedying alienation. Whilst I think typically we see conventional psychology as being really focused on the connection between humans and our mind and our behaviour, eco-psychology is focused on the emotional psychology.
但这些问题也更广泛地与健康专家所称的“缺乏运动流行病”联系在一起。我们的生活在室内。它们是受限制的。而且我们非常错过了自然能为我们提供的治愈能力。这种理解实际上有很多科学支持，以至于研究人员创建了一个全新的学科，叫做生态心理学（ecopsychology），来检查这种非常普遍的体验。因此，生态心理学有兴趣了解我们如何加强个人与自然环境之间的联系，目的是治疗某些心理健康状况或促进联系、纠正疏离感。虽然我认为通常我们认为传统心理学非常关注人类与我们的心灵和行为之间的联系，但生态心理学关注的是情感心理学。
is focused on the emotional bond and the connection between humans and the earth. The essential idea is that we have become detached from our evolutionary roots. And by restoring our connection with our minds, with nature, we can psychologically almost heal some of the modern day things that are impacting a lot of people. You know, our external environment becomes a lot more industrialized and clinical. That's a big concern because our brains are still attuned to the ways of nature through centuries and centuries of evolution. And by depriving it of that source of stimulation and energy, we're kind of limiting what
专注于人类与地球之间的情感纽带和联系。核心观点是，我们已经脱离了我们的进化之根。通过恢复我们与思想、与自然的联系，我们在心理上几乎可以治愈一些正在影响许多人的现代事物。你知道，我们的外部环境变得更加工业化和临床化。这是一个大问题，因为通过几个世纪又几个世纪的进化，我们的大脑仍然适应着自然的方式。通过剥夺它的刺激和能量来源，我们有点在限制
aspects and areas of our brain that we can use, what our brain is actually capable of. This idea has several fundamental principles, ecosycology in general. And I think they're incredibly powerful. So I'm going to list a few here before we jump into the actual research, because I actually think a lot of us innately believe this. So here are some of the principles. Firstly, there is this synergetic interplay between the planet, between Earth and our personal well-being. The core of our mind is ecologically conscious. The goal of ecopsychology is to awaken that inherent sense of environmental reciprocity that lies.
我们大脑可以使用的方面和领域，以及我们大脑的实际能力。这个想法有几个基本原则，生态心理学总体而言。我认为它们非常强大。所以在我跳进实际研究之前，我在这里列举几个，因为我实际上认为我们很多人天生就相信这一点。所以这里有一些原则。首先，地球、地球与我们的个人福祉之间存在着协同相互作用。我们心灵的核心是生态意识。生态心理学旨在唤醒那种内在的生态互惠感。
between us and the natural environment. And finally, the ecological ego matures towards a sense of ethical responsibility with the planet. And that's something we want to cultivate. I think it's really interesting, if not quite frustrating, like I said, that this discipline doesn't really get the attention and the love and the credit it deserves. I think because of this very detached clinical approach to psychology that has dominated the field for many, many years. We have become increasingly focused on pharmaceutical interventions and treatment of symptoms rather than a holistic approach to our emotional and mental well-being. I'm not discrediting that at all. I really hope that is not taken out of context.
在我们与自然环境之间。最后，生态自我向着对地球的道德责任感成熟。这是我们想要培养的东西。我认为这非常有趣，如果不是相当令人沮丧的话，正如我所说，这个学科并没有真正得到它应有的关注、爱和赞誉。我认为是因为这种非常疏离的、临床的心理学方法在许多年里一直主导着这个领域。我们越来越专注于药物干预和症状治疗，而不是对我们的情感和心理健康的整体方法。我一点也没有贬低这一点。我真的希望这不会被断章取义。
I definitely personally have benefited and will continue to benefit from medical interventions for my mental health. But I think our discussions should be a lot more nuanced and inclusive of different options and different sources of healing. Luckily for us, more and more research is being devoted to this. So I want to cover some of the major studies. One of the biggest ones was conducted in the UK and they conducted the study of around 20,000 people and they found that people who spent two hours a week in green spaces that could literally just be your local park. They were substantially more likely to report good health
我个人绝对从心理健康医疗干预中受益，并将继续受益。但我认为我们的讨论应该更加细致，并且包容不同的选择和不同的治愈来源。对我们来说幸运的是，越来越多的研究投入到了这一点。所以我想涵盖一些主要的研究。其中最大的一项是在英国进行的，他们对大约2万人进行了研究，发现每周在绿地中花两个小时的人——这实际上可能只是你当地的公园——他们更有可能报告身体健康状况良好。
and psychological well-being than those who don't. And the cut-off was literally two hours. Anything less than that, we didn't start to see the same benefits. Similarly, all these psychiatric unit researchers, they've been finding that being in nature, it has reduced feelings of isolation, it's promoted a sense of calmness, and it's a sense of calmness, and it's even lifted the mood amongst their patients who are undergoing treatment for various psychiatric disorders. Actually, in one of the, possibly the earliest actually, observations on this, this was like 200 years ago. Back in 1812, this physician, he worked with mental health patients, and he found that his patients who had to pay for their treatment by doing yard work on the
和心理健康状况比那些不这样做的人。而分界线实际上就是两个小时。任何少于这个时间的人，我们都没有开始看到同样的好处。同样，所有这些精神科病房的研究人员发现，身处大自然中减少了孤立感，促进了平静感，甚至提升了正在接受各种精神疾病治疗的患者的情绪。事实上，在其中一个可能最早的观察中，这大约是200年。早在1812年，这位医生与精神健康患者合作，他发现那些必须通过做庭院工作来支付治疗费用的患者
hospital grounds. So they were outside for at least three to four hours, essentially doing manual labor in nature to pay for their treatment. They actually recovered faster than the wealthier patients who could afford the cost of treatment and who kind of just walked around inside and stayed inside for much of the day. That really flips what we would typically see. It's also worth noting this is an observation. This isn't a study. But it is kind of backed up by more of those experimental conditions and experimental research that has come out in recent years. One in 2019 at the University of Chicago, these two researchers examined the influence of local green environments on people in cities and large communities, large concrete communities.
医院场地。所以他们在户外至少呆了三到四个小时，本质上是在大自然中进行体力劳动来支付治疗费用。他们实际上比那些支付得起治疗费用并在室内四处走动并在室内呆了大部分时间的较富裕患者恢复得更快。这完全颠覆了我们通常看到的现象。同样值得注意的是，这是一个观察结果。这不是一项研究。但这得到了近年来出现的更多实验条件和实验研究的支持。2019年，芝加哥大学的两名研究人员研究了当地绿色环境对城市和大社区、大型混凝土社区人们的影响。
And they found that green spaces near schools really promote cognitive development in children. even just seeing greenery, they don't even have to be in it, promotes this sense of well-being and emotional and cognitive development. That's been backed up. They did this incredibly, I think it is possibly one of the largest longitudinal studies ever conducted. These researchers in Denmark, they examined data from more than 900,000, yes, close to a million, 900,000 children, born between 1985 and 2005.
他们发现学校附近的绿地确实促进了儿童的认知发展。甚至仅仅看到绿色植物，他们甚至不必身处其中，也能促进幸福感以及情绪和认知发展。这得到了证实。他们做了一项非常惊人的研究，我认为这可能是历史上规模最大的纵向研究之一。丹麦的这些研究人员查阅了1985年至2005年间出生的90万名，是的，接近100万名，90万名儿童的数据，
and they found that those kids who lived in neighborhoods with more green space had a reduced risk of many psychiatric disorders later in life, including depression, mood disorders, schizophrenia, eating disorders. I will say one of the things that really, I think, conflates with that finding or maybe is an extraneous variable is the influence of wealth, you know, people who make more money can afford to buy homes with backyards or in really affluent suburbs where they have well-maintained public parks. And obviously, as we say in psychology, correlation is not causation. And we are by no means suggesting that a hike is going to cure someone's major mood disorder. But it is something
他们发现，生活在绿地较多的社区里的孩子在日后患许多精神疾病的风险降低了，包括抑郁症、情绪障碍、精神分裂症、进食障碍。我要说的是，真正与该发现在某种程度上重合或可能是一个无关变量的因素之一是财富的影响，你知道，赚更多钱的人买得起带后院的房子或买得起维护良好的公共公园的富裕郊区。显然，正如我们在心理学中所说，相关性并不等于因果关系。我们绝不是暗示一次徒步旅行就能治愈某人的重大情绪障碍。但这是
to note. And I think it's part of that larger tapestry of evidence. We've also seen that people assigned to public housing units in neighbourhood with more green space, showed better attentional functioning than those assigned to units with less access to natural environments. And just being exposed to nature, it really improves things like our working memory. Whilst exposure to urban environments, particularly through childhood to adulthood, is linked to attention deficits, maybe even at the extreme, and this is very much, much at the extreme things like ADHD. It may also go way deeper than that. It just provides a general sense of well-being that also helps to reduce things like crime and aggression. Back in 2015,
值得注意。我认为这是更大的证据拼图的一部分。我们还发现，被分配到绿地较多社区的公共住房单元的人，比分配到自然环境较少单元的人表现出更好的注意力功能。仅仅接触大自然，确实能改善我们的工作记忆等事情。而接触城市环境，特别是在童年到成年期间，与注意力缺陷有关，甚至在极端情况下，这是非常极端的，比如多动症。它可能比这更深。它只是提供了一种普遍的幸福感，也有助于减少犯罪和攻击性等事情。早在2015年，
also in the UK, they're really pushing a lot of this research at the moment. They conducted a study on 2,000 people and they found that more exposure to the natural environment translated into more community cohesion and substantially lower crime rates. Once again, we have to think about the other variables there, things like wealth, but all of these findings are just combining to show that nature is an integral part of our well-being, of our physical health, of our mental health, of our emotional health, that we don't only neglect, but the environments that we now live in are neglecting for us. The reason I wanted to provide so many examples, examples is because I want to kind of show the diversity of the impacts. It's not just about
同样在英国，他们目前正在大力推进这项研究。他们对2000人进行了研究，发现接触更多自然环境转化为更多的社区凝聚力和大幅降低的犯罪率。再次，我们必须考虑那里的其他变量，比如财富，但所有这些发现结合起来表明，自然是我们福祉、身体健康、心理健康、情感健康不可或缺的一部分，我们不仅忽视了它，而且我们现在生活的环境也在为我们忽视它。我之所以想提供这么多的例子，是因为我想展示影响的多样性。这不仅仅关于
our psychological well-being, but it's about sense of community. It's about physical health. It's about loneliness. The list is like honestly endless. This is just like a minor cross-section of all that is going into kind of pushing the field of eco-psychology along. However, the idea that nature has these innate healing properties is by no means a new one. It has a really rich and diverse history. It spans across the world, Japan, Finland, Australia, Italy, especially in a lot of indigenous cultures. Perhaps that's another reason why it's sometimes discredited. Western medicine is very much plagued by what we would call biological reductionism. It's always looking for some internal pathological origin of a lot of our
我们的心理健康，但也关乎社区感。它关乎身体健康。它关乎孤独感。这个列表简直无休无止。这只是推动生态心理学领域发展的所有研究的一个微小横截面。然而，自然拥有这些与生俱来的治愈特性的观点绝不是新鲜事。它有着丰富而多元的历史。它遍布世界各地，日本、芬兰、澳大利亚、意大利，特别是在许多原住民文化中。这也许是它有时被贬低的另一个原因。西方医学深受我们所谓的生物还原论的困扰。它总是寻找我们许多疾病的某种内部病理根源，而不是向外看环境中发生的事情，这些事情可能会让我们有这种感觉。多年来，许多原住民和非西方文化中存在着惊人的知识量，他们一直在声称这一点。一直都在这样说。所以我接下来真正想关注的是，在接触自然与为什么自然如此强大之间，已经建立了哪些历史和文化联系？我们的大脑和身体中究竟发生了什么来促进这些结果？当然，在这个日益数字化、工业化的世界里，
problems rather than looking externally to what's happening in our environment that might be making us feel this way. And for many, many years, there has been this amazing amount of knowledge in a lot of indigenous and non-Western cultures that has been claiming that. That has been saying that. So what I really want to focus on next is what are some of these historical and cultural links that have been made between exposure to nature and well why is nature so powerful? What is actually happening in our brains and our bodies to promote these outcomes? And of course, in this increasingly digitalized world, in this industrialized world,
我们如何将这些实践融入我们极其忙碌的生活中？我知道我站在这个讲台上或肥皂盒上说“我们需要花更多的时间在大自然中”很容易，但我知道我们中的许多人会觉得，那太不现实了。所以让我们来谈谈我们如何真正做到这一点。这比我们想象的要容易得多。所以所有这些以及更多内容将在稍后揭晓。2%。
how do we integrate these practices into our very busy lives? I know it's very easy for me to kind of stand up on this podium or my soapbox and be like, we need to spend more time in nature. but I know a lot of us are like, that is so unrealistic. So let's talk through how we can actually do that. It's a lot easier than we think. So all of that and more in just a second. 2%.
这是当电梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、
That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers. researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out
研究人员和其他健康与健身专家等展开对话，超越主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的认为种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在这个世界上恐慌的许多问题
about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast.
都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端变成一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方搜索TWO percent。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小肯姆（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不喜欢黑人。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小肯姆到底有什么关系？嗯，你可以在《回顾过去》播客中找到答案。
I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack,
我是萨姆·杰特（Sam Jett）。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一集有马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）作客，大谈80年代的霹雳可卡因（crack）。需要说明的是，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为霹雳可卡因。我随时准备聊聊84年的可卡因，但只是让你们知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论霹雳可卡因的第二集了，
so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so. Then you're finishing that sentence. Yes, I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years. for black people in American history.
所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿线。我们现在还有艾滋病摆在桌面上，所以。然后你接着说那句话。是的，我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人来说最重要的一年。
Listen to look back at it on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark.
在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾过去》。欢迎来到我的新播客《以艰难的方式学习》，我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师凯尔·盖恩斯。为了纪念心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，并与许多不可思议的嘉宾进行了对话。我说的是，特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。
Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch life becomes about wins and losses Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro.
有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太陷入追逐之中，以至于我们没有意识到我们已经拥有了这样东西，而我们还在追逐它，我们不知道什么时候才算够了，因为人们盯着记分牌，生活变成了输赢史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你发现作为一个好人很重要当你在这个地球上的时候，还是你因为害怕而成为一个好人？因为那是两种不同的意图，兄弟。
Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal.
绝对的。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真正成为一个好人。加入我，凯尔·盖恩斯（Kear Gaines），我们在我的新播客《以艰难的方式学习》中就治愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标进行真实的对话。打开免费的iHeartRadio应用程序。搜索《以艰难的方式学习》并立即收听。在2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Echard）发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。
The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Sond's, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern.
随后的家庭法庭听证会揭示了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这开始了长达数年的法庭斗争以证明真相。桑兹女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一支网络侦探大队来破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的税金被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会发现一个令人不安的模式。
Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alesspian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges.
另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安（Greg Alesspian）、迈克尔·马兰蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我的脑子炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《爱的陷阱》（Love Trap）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着季数的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。
This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. One of the best examples of a modern day nature therapy or practice is called Forest Bathing or Shinran Yurku in Japanese. This idea emerged in Japan in the early 1980s and the purpose was to literally take time to bathe in nature. It's not about exercise, it's not about trying to count your calories or get fit or hiking or jogging, but connecting with nature through all of our senses, through sight, hearing, taste, touch and smell. and by doing this, kind of opening those pathways back up to the natural world.
在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这不算完。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《爱的陷阱》播客。现代自然疗法或实践的最佳例子之一被称为“森林浴”（Forest Bathing）或日语中的“森林浴”（Shinrin-Yoku）。这个想法于20世纪80年代初起源于日本，其目的字面意思是花时间在大自然中沐浴。这与锻炼无关，与试图计算卡路里、健身、徒步旅行或慢跑无关，而是通过我们所有的感官——视觉、听觉、味觉、触觉和嗅觉——与自然建立联系。通过这样做，某种程度上重新打通了通往自然世界的那些路径。
It's actually become a vital part of preventative healthcare in Japan. Some doctors will literally prescribe forest bathing to burnt out office workers. And the government has actually invested in this. They've done a series of studies and they found that this practice improved sleep quality, mood, reduced stress levels. there's a really good book on this very practice. It's called Forest Bathing, How Trees Can Help You Find Health and Happiness. A friend gave it to me last year, maybe a couple years ago, and it's really incredible. It's really quite profound seeing how, I guess, what we can bring to our lives and how we can, like, elevate our experiences with nature.
这实际上已成为日本预防保健的重要部分。一些医生甚至会给精疲力竭的上班族开出森林浴的处方。政府实际上也对此进行了投资。他们做了一系列研究，发现这种实践改善了睡眠质量、情绪，减少了压力水平。有一本关于这种实践的非常好的书。书名叫《森林浴：树木如何帮您找到健康与幸福》（Forest Bathing, How Trees Can Help You Find Health and Happiness）。一个朋友去年送给我的，也许是几年前，这真的很不可思议。看到我们能为生活带来什么，以及我们如何能够，比如说，提升我们在大自然中的体验，这真的非常深刻。
There's also this idea in ancient China of Chi, which is the vital connection between, humans and the earth and that connection has formed a big part of the naturopathy movement in the 19th century other countries and cultures have very similar ideas or practices for promoting a spiritual and psychological reconnection with nature in a lot of Scandinavian countries they have these things called forest schools in australia we call them bush schools and essentially the premise is that learning should take place in a natural setting where children are able to explore and discover away from screens and away from kind of some of those traditional learning practices. It's also called Woodland or Free Range Learning, like Free Range Chickens.
中国古代还有“气”的概念，即人与地球之间的生命力联系，这种联系在19世纪的其他国家和文化中形成了自然疗法运动的重要部分，有着非常相似的想法或实践，用于促进与自然的精神和心理重新连接。在许多斯堪的纳维亚国家，他们有被称为森林学校（forest schools）的东西，在澳大利亚我们称之为丛林学校（bush schools），其核心前提是学习应该在自然环境中进行，让孩子们能够在远离屏幕和某些传统学习实践的地方进行探索和发现。它也被称为林地或自由放养学习，就像自由放养的鸡一样。
And the idea came about in the 1990s amongst this small group of Danish educators that although their schools may not have an actual classroom, they could provide a better learning experience. I think if you've always been raised in a really conventional idea of what schooling should be, this may seem like kind of bizarre, maybe a bit abstract. But I remember spending so much time in nature as a child. Me and my sisters and my cousins, we would go and explore the bush with my granddad, and we would plant flowers and make mud patties and swim in the creek.
这个想法出现在19世纪90年代的一小群丹麦教育工作者中，他们认为，尽管他们的学校可能没有真正的教室，但他们可以提供更好的学习体验。我想，如果你一直是在一个对学校应该是什么样的传统观念中长大，这可能看起来有点离奇，甚至有点抽象。但我记得童年时花了很多时间和自然在一起。我和我的姐姐们、表亲们会和我的外公一起去探索丛林，我们会在那里种花、做泥饼、在小溪里游泳。
I remember those memories so clearly. They're like a massive part of my identity. But you know what I don't remember? I do not remember a single thing about my primary school classroom. Not a single thing. I think the only thing I can remember is like the class pets that we had and like standardised testing. I'm not saying that I didn't learn important things during that time. But a lot of that could have been elevated and I probably would have benefited
我记得那些记忆非常清晰。它们是我身份的很大一部分。但你知道我不记得什么吗？我不记得我小学的教室里的任何事情。连一件事都不记得。我想我能记住的唯一事情就是我们养的班级宠物和标准化考试。我不是说我在那段时间里没有学到重要的东西。但其中很多是可以提升的，如果我能有一个更加融合的课堂体验，将户外活动与某些狂野和自然的体验结合起来，我可能会受益良多。幸运的是，多亏了我的父母，我在休闲时间已经得到了这些体验。而我真的很为那些没有得到这种体验的孩子感到难过。我认为他们真的错失了部分自然的 A。
from a more integrated classroom experience that combined the outdoors, which luckily I was already getting in like my leisure time, thanks to my parents. But combined that with some of those wild and natural experiences. And I feel really bad for kids who don't get that. I think they really miss out on some of that natural curiosity. I've also been contemplating this idea a lot in terms of my future children. Maybe that's an idea we should do on the show.
我也一直在考虑这个想法，关于我未来的孩子。也许这是我们应该在节目中讨论的一个想法。
Like, I don't know what it was, but I, like, entered my, like, mid-20s and was, like, couldn't stop thinking about children. We need to talk about that, actually. But sidebar, I've been thinking a lot in terms of the kids that I want to raise someday. And I would want my children to be a little bit wild, to always be a little bit dirty and a little bit messy. I think there is so much of this recent science that shows how valuable those early experiences and that spiritual and psychological connection with nature, how profound and powerful that could be.
就像，我不知道是怎么回事，我，就像，进入了我的，像，二十岁中期，然后，就像，停不下来地想着孩子。实际上我们需要谈谈那个。但话说回来，我一直在考虑我希望有一天能抚养的孩子。我希望我的孩子能有点野性，总是有点脏兮兮、有点邋遢。我认为有很多近期的科学表明，那些早期的经历以及与自然的精神和心理联系是多么有价值，这是多么深刻和强大。
And so when I think about how I would want to raise perhaps future children, future versions of me, I kind of reflect on what that says about my priorities right now and how I can reflect that in my own life. I will say, this idea has existed for a long time and a lot of indigenous cultures have known what Western medicine and psychology is only just, figuring out, and they've known it for thousands and thousands of years. In Australia, our First
所以当我在思考我希望如何抚养未来的孩子、未来版本的我时，我有点在反思这对我现在的优先事项意味着什么，以及我如何在自己的生活中反映这一点。我要说的是，这个想法已经存在了很长时间，许多原住民文化早就知道了西方医学和心理学才刚刚开始弄清楚的事情，他们已经知道了几千年。在澳大利亚，我们的第一
Nations people, specifically Aboriginal and Torres Strait Islander people who are the oldest known civilization on earth. They have such a deep idea of country and connection to the land, and I think this connection is difficult for non-Indigenous people to grasp, something we can learn a lot from, because these groups, these cultures have long known about and use the healer. properties of nature. There was a really fascinating article that I read when researching this idea and it discusses this concept of barefoot healing or earthing that allows us to feel present in nature and acknowledge the interconnectedness between us and kind of every living thing. And the Maori people of New Zealand, I know that they also have kind of a similar philosophy and connection
民族人民，特别是原住民和托雷斯海峡岛民，他们是地球上已知最古老的文明。他们有着如此深厚的土地和连接意识，我认为这种连接对于非原住民来说很难掌握，这是我们可以从中学到很多东西的，因为这些群体、这些文化很早就知道并使用了治疗。自然的属性。我在研究这个想法时读到了一篇非常引人入胜的文章，它讨论了赤脚疗愈（barefoot healing）或接地气（earthing）的概念，这使我们能够在自然中感受到当下的存在，并承认我们与每一种生物之间的相互联系。新西兰的毛利人，我知道他们也有一种类似的哲学和联系
to the land. So many cultures, so many societies have known about this. So why is it that this practice could prove so valuable for this current generation? How do we adopt this kind of learning and understanding? What are the psychological explanations that can be offered for these deep shifts that we see in our emotional state and see in our mental well-being? To answer that, we need to look at the neural and global structures of the brain and how our brain has evolved to adapt to our environment, specifically the role of this new brain. When we think about the activities that were crucial for our survival and therefore have the greatest role in the evolution of our brains, these are around things like foraging and hunting. And both activities obviously occurred in a natural
与土地。如此多的文化，如此多的社会都了解这一点。那么为什么这种实践对当今这一代人如此有价值呢？我们如何采用这种学习和理解？对于我们在情绪状态和心理健康中看到的这些深刻转变，可以提供哪些心理学解释？为了回答这个问题，我们需要看看大脑的神经和整体结构，以及我们的大脑如何进化以适应我们的环境，特别是这个新大脑的作用。当我们思考对我们的生存至关重要、因此在我们大脑进化中发挥最大作用的活动时，这些活动围绕着诸如寻觅和狩猎之类的事情。显然，这两项活动都是在自然环境中发生的
environment. I want to focus mainly on foraging here. We used to spend our days searching for food, for useful resources, for berries, for sustenance. What that involved was a really complex cognitive process, constant exposure to new stimuli, a rich environment, and choice options and cost-benefit analysis, problem-solving. Crucially, what this also meant is that when we were doing this, we were using different parts of our brain and building different synaptic connections that created a larger and more cognitively complex structure. That is our current brain.
环境。我想把这里的重点放在寻觅食物上。我们过去常常把时间花在寻找食物、有用的资源、浆果和维持生计上。这涉及到一个非常复杂的认知过程、不断接触新的刺激、丰富的环境以及选择方案、成本效益分析和解决问题。至关重要的是，这也意味着当我们这样做时，我们正在使用大脑的不同部分并建立不同的突触连接，从而创造一个更大、认知更复杂的结构。这就是我们当前的大脑。
It's at this point of evolution as we started really, I guess old humans, ancient humans, whatever you want to call them, as they started building these neural networks, as they started exploring more and problem solving more, we saw this idea of the new brain. We saw this new brain begin to develop. and that is what truly made us human. That is where we see our identity form, our personality, our social skills.
正是在这个进化阶段，当我们开始真正，我想说的是远古人类，无论你想怎么称呼他们，当他们开始建立这些神经网络，当他们开始更多地探索和解决问题时，我们看到了新大脑的概念。我们看到这个新大脑开始发育。这才是真正让我们成为人类的原因。正是在这里，我们看到了我们的身份、个性和社交技能的形成。
And all of that has evolved within an environment of natural fulfillment. Therefore, the more and more detached we become from these surroundings, the more and more we see those negative mental consequences that we've discussed. Our modern day environment does not stimulate this same activity or cognitive thrill. when we're trying to navigate our concrete cities, we're doing monotonous daily tasks, flashing screens, that constant spike in dopamine enlisted by social media, all of that requires the kind of attention that is incredibly procedural and automatic. It doesn't take much from us cognitively or emotionally.
所有这些都在自然满足的环境中进化。因此，我们与这些周围环境的脱节程度越高，我们所看到的那些我们讨论过的负面心理后果就越严重。我们现代的环境并没有激发同样的活动或认知刺激。当我们试图在混凝土城市中穿行时，我们正在做单调的日常任务，闪烁的屏幕，社交媒体不断引起的多巴胺激增，所有这一切都需要那种极其程序化和自动化的注意力。它在认知或情感上没有对我们提出太多要求。
When we think about the comparison between, say, the use of social media and natural scavenging, Social media is designed to hijack our reward system and to give us a very immediate dopamine hit that is highly addictive because it doesn't require much effort, but it also gives us less satisfaction. When we compare that to activities where we are actively curious about our environment and in a process of discovery, that creates a slower release of dopamine that is more fulfilling. and that slow release effect also means that it lasts for longer. I have a very particular vitro towards screens because we have consistently seen that more and more hours and daily exposure to laptops to phones, it's associated with lower psychological well-being because it is so limited.
当我们考虑诸如使用社交媒体与自然寻觅食物之间的比较时，社交媒体旨在劫持我们的奖励系统，并给我们带来非常即时的高成瘾性多巴胺冲击，因为它不需要太多努力，但它也带给我们较少的满足感。与那些让我们对环境充满积极好奇并处于发现过程中的活动相比，这会产生更慢、更能满足需求的多巴胺释放。这种缓慢释放的效果还意味着它能持续更长时间。我对屏幕有一种非常特殊的反感，因为我们一直看到，越来越多的小时数和每日接触笔记本电脑、手机的习惯与较低的心理健康水平有关，因为它是如此局限。
Same colors, same apps, same daily activities. in a natural environment, however, we pay attention more broadly in a way that is rewarding, which leads to a far more relaxed body and a relaxed mind. It's also been found that exposure to nature reduces cortisol levels. Cortisol is the hormone that is responsible for our stress response. And when our levels of cortisol are elevated for a long time, we see things like increased illnesses, increased sickness, increased blood pressure. So putting ourselves in nature also reduces our likelihood of developing some of those
相同的颜色，相同的应用程序，相同的日常活动。然而，在自然环境中，我们以一种有益的方式更广泛地关注，这会带来更加放松的身体和放松的心理。人们还发现，接触大自然可以降低皮质醇水平。皮质醇是负责我们压力反应的激素。当我们的皮质醇水平长时间升高时，我们会看到诸如疾病增加、生病增多、血压升高的情况。因此，让自己置身于大自然中也会降低我们患上其中一些疾病的可能性。
chronic health problems as well. There's also been this study floating around social media recently, which claims that seeing water improves our mental health. I will admit, I was a bit skeptical because any time I see psychological skills, studies or conclusions online that don't have a source. Half of the time, they're not true. But surprisingly, this one actually is. This study was published in the American Association of Advancement Science, and it found that staring at the ocean actually changes our brainwave frequency and can put us in almost a mild meditative state. Water seems to have this specifically,
慢性健康问题也是如此。最近社交媒体上流传着这样一项研究，声称看到水可以改善我们的心理健康。我承认，我有点怀疑，因为任何时候我在网上看到没有来源的心理学技能研究或结论。有一半时间，它们都不是真的。但令人惊讶的是，这个是真的。这项研究发表在《美国科学促进会》杂志上，发现凝视海洋实际上会改变我们的脑电波频率，并能让我们进入几乎温和的冥想状态。水似乎具有这种特殊的、
psychologically restorative effect. Maybe it's because of the sunlight, less polluted air, but we know that it significantly improves our mood and our mental well-being. And finally, nature offers novelty. When we are used to our habitual patterns and daily routine, the scrolling, the work commute, what we're missing out on is new experiences. And research shows that novelty triggers the release of dopamine in the brain as a reward, encouraging us to be more curious and to be more motivated. That may be the reason why we see this healing power of nature. It's the newness. It's the break from the usual that stimulates this ancient evolutionary need. So how do we integrate this? Especially when our lives are so busy and for those who are living in cities,
心理恢复作用。也许是因为阳光，污染较少的空气，但我们知道它显著改善了我们的情绪和心理健康。最后，大自然提供了新奇感。当我们习惯了习惯性的模式和日常工作，滑动屏幕、通勤上班时，我们错过的是新的体验。研究表明，新奇感会触发大脑中多巴胺的释放作为一种奖励，鼓励我们更有好奇心和动力。这可能是我们看到大自然这种治愈力量的原因。这就是新鲜感。这是对寻常事物的打破，激发了这种古老的进化需求。那么我们如何整合这一点呢？特别是当我们的生活如此忙碌，对于那些住在城市里的人来说，
we are in these highly developed environments. I think it's all about what you choose to prioritize. The easiest thing we can do is what is most convenient. You could spend your weekends watching TV. You could spend your weekends drinking, spending hours on your phone, or you can make the conscious decision to do what you know will be better for you psychologically in the long term. The choice is really yours.
我们处于这些高度发达的环境中。我认为这完全取决于你选择优先考虑什么。我们可以做的最简单的事情就是最方便的事情。你可以把周末花在看电视上。你可以把周末花在喝酒、花几个小时玩手机上，或者你可以做出有意识的决定，去做你长远来看对心理更有益的事情。选择其实在你。
You are the only one who gets to make that decision. And it's about deciding what kind of life you're prepared to live. Plan a weekend trip, a weekend hike with your friends. Make it an exciting activity to kind of look towards and carry you through the week. The other thing is to make like a bit of a bucket list of local nature spots, beaches, picnic locations, or just make the time to do normal activities in these locations. like exercising, catching up with friends, rather than going to a bar, go to the local park. You're going to save money, but also get that nature fix.
你是唯一能做出那个决定的人。这是关于决定你准备过什么样的生活。计划一次周末旅行，和朋友一起周末徒步旅行。让它成为一项令人兴奋的活动，期待它并支撑你度过这一周。另一件事是做一个当地自然景点、海滩、野餐地点的愿望清单，或者只是腾出时间在这些地方进行正常的活动。比如锻炼，和朋友叙旧，而不是去酒吧，去当地的公园。你会省钱，还能得到亲近大自然的机会。
I think it's all about slowly reprogramming those hijacked dopamine systems to be positioned towards the outdoors, rather than indoor screen-based activities. One thing I love doing is planning trips with a big group of friends that are based around nature. The best kind is a coast trip. Everyone loves a coast trip. Everyone loves a little beach holiday. And you'll also get the benefit of breaking up your usual environment with this natural novel experience. I think it's not just about the big things though, these very large time and energy commitments. In a lot of those studies that we've spoken about, they reference consistent, frequent exposure. and I know that can feel really hard in big cities or when you're super busy.
我认为这一切都是为了慢慢重新编程那些被劫持的多巴胺系统，使其朝向户外，而不是室内的屏幕活动。我最喜欢做的一件事是策划一整群朋友以大自然为基础的旅行。最好的那种是海岸旅行。每个人都喜欢海岸旅行。每个人都喜欢小小的海滩度假。你还将获得打破惯常环境并获得这种自然新奇体验的好处。不过我认为这不仅仅是关于大事，这些非常耗时耗力的承诺。在我们讨论过的许多研究中，他们提到了持续、频繁的接触，我知道在大城市里或当你超级忙碌时，这会让人感到非常困难。
I think that's the other problem I often found when I was working full time was that when the sun rises at 8 and it sets at 4 and your daytime is consumed with work, how is it even possible to get that necessary outdoor time? It's all about the small habits, the daily rituals, finding a way to program nature into your everyday routine. We all eat lunch. So find a way to eat lunch outside, walk to work in the mornings if you can, or just try and get up early for a nice stroll. Take 10 minutes to just sit in the sun and feel the wind, hear the sounds, the sensation of it on your face, what it smells like, what sounds it's carrying,
我想这也是我全职工作时经常发现的另一个问题，当太阳在8点升起，4点落下，而你的白天被工作消耗时，怎么可能抽出必要的时间去户外呢？这一切都关乎微小的习惯，日常的仪式，找到将大自然融入日常生活的方法。我们都要吃午饭。所以想办法在外面吃午饭，早上能走路上班就走路上班，或者试着早起散步。花10分钟坐在阳光下，感受微风，聆听声音，感受它打在脸上的触感，它的气味，它带来什么声音，
or challenge yourself to just leave your house every day, even if it's just to walk down the road. those small moments of exposure are cumulative and I think better than doing nothing at all. I also want to take a quick moment here to shout out some of my favorite books and further resources on this topic because if you have not noticed, I'm very obsessed with this concept and this entire idea of eco-psychology at the moment. I think it's so important, it's not spoken about enough and so valuable. rewilding is also a really important idea in this space and this amazing book called rewilding the urban soul is incredible for understanding this i'm also strangely a huge fan of into the wild i maybe this doesn't sit here
或者挑战自己每天出门，哪怕只是沿着马路走走。那些微小的接触时刻是累积的，我认为总比什么都不做要好。我还想在这里花一点时间感谢一下我最喜欢的一些关于这个主题的书籍和进一步的资源，因为如果你没有注意到的话，我目前非常沉迷于这个概念和生态心理学的整个想法。我认为这太重要了，没有被足够谈论而且非常宝贵。野化也是这个领域一个非常重要的理念，这本名为《野化都市灵魂》的惊人书籍对于理解这一点非常不可思议，而且我奇怪地也是《荒野生存》的超级粉丝，也许这不属于这里
but i think that this movie is incredible sometimes what we need is not nature itself but that motivation to actually be present and i don't know what it is about this film But every time I watch it, I just have this urge to go and hike like the Pacific Crest Trail. It's a must watch. And finally, losing Eden by Lucy Jones, if you love neuroscience, if you love psychology, this book is so profound and really, really convincing. I really hope this episode has, at the very least, left you with something to contemplate. I hope that maybe you are on a little stroll while you are listening to this. If you are, send me a photo.
但我认为这部电影非常不可思议，有时我们需要的不是大自然本身，而是实际存在的动力，我不知道这部电影有什么魔力，但每次我看它时，我都有一种去徒步像太平洋屋脊步道这样的冲动。这是一部必看的电影。最后，由露西·琼斯所著的《失去伊甸园》，如果你喜欢神经科学，如果你喜欢心理学，这本书非常深刻而且非常、非常有说服力。我真的希望这一集至少能给你留下一些可以思考的东西。我希望也许你在听这个的时候正在散步。如果是，请给我发张照片。
We'll definitely repost it to my Instagram because that is so cool. But I just think that nature is such a amazing psychological tool and resource that we don't often use. So some food for thought, if you will. I really enjoyed this episode. I want to talk about this a lot more. So maybe we'll do a part two. We'll never know. If you have an episode suggestion, as always, please feel free to follow me at That Psychology
我们一定会把它重新发布到我的Instagram上，因为那太酷了。但我只是认为大自然是一个如此了不起的心理工具和资源，我们经常没有使用它。所以，如果你愿意的话，这里有一些引人深思的东西。我真的很喜欢这一集。我想更多地讨论这个。所以也许我们会做第二部分。谁知道呢。如果你有剧集建议，一如既往，请随时关注我：That Psychology
podcast and follow along to see what's coming up. You can find our new merch. You can just look at video content of my show, whatever. Whatever suits your fancy. Also, we have a Patreon now that I plugged at the beginning. It's just me doing this show, writing these episodes and creating this content. So any support that you can provide is really, really meaningful. you also get access to bonus content, so many good things.
播客并关注接下来的内容。你可以找到我们的新周边。你可以只看我的节目的视频内容，随你便。任何适合你喜好的。另外，我们现在有Patreon，我在开头安利过了。这只有我一个人在做这个节目，写这些剧集并创作这些内容。所以你能提供的任何支持都是非常、非常有意义的。你还可以获得访问独家内容的权限，有这么多好东西。
And as always, if you feel compelled to do so, please feel free to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you're listening right now, and share with a friend. You never know who it will benefit. So thank you so much for listening along, tagging along today with this episode. We will be back next week for another one.
一如既往，如果你觉得有必要这样做，请随时在Apple Podcasts、Spotify或你现在正在收听的任何地方留下五星好评，并与朋友分享。你永远不知道它会使谁受益。非常感谢大家收听今天的节目。我们下周将带着另一集回归。
Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%.
嘿，最近怎么样，各位？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯主持的《用困难的方式学习》。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，而在其他地方进行这些对话实在是不安全的，但你是在与一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在AHA广播应用程序、Apple Podcast或你获取播客的任何地方收听《用困难的方式学习》。2%。
That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is only a lot. Also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side,
这是只有很多人的时候选择走楼梯的人的比例。同时也有自动扶梯可用。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理坚韧、健康和韧性的科学。让自己经历一些磨难，你就会从另一端走出来，
a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. They take matters into their own hands.
一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即TWO%。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都约会过同一个多产的骗子时。她们采取了行动。
I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that, trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts,
我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他不会逃脱惩罚的。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。听女朋友的话。相信我，宝贝。在Iheart radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts、
or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. Eighty-4 was big two. I'm Sam J And I'm Alex English Each episode We pick a year
或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《回顾它》播客中。从1979年开始，这对我和我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年也很重要。我是萨姆·J，我是亚历克斯·英格利希，每一集我们都会选择一个年份
unpack what went down And try to make sense of how we survived it With our friends, fellow comedians and favorite authors Like Mark Lamont Hill On the 80s It was a wild year
剖析发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何在我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员和像马克·拉蒙特·希尔这样的最喜欢的作者的陪伴下度过难关的。在80年代，那是一个疯狂的年份
I don't think there's a more important year for black people Listen to look back at it On the IHeart Radio app Apple Podcasts Or wherever you get your podcasts This is an IHeart podcast Guaranteed Human
我认为没有比这对于黑人来说更重要的年份了。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾它》。这是一个IHeart播客。保证人类
Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
谢谢。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录中的任意句子即可留下评论。